I don't want to end the sloppy farce I
guess that's why
you leaked information at the sports festival this time,
so class c was able to handle things
well.
I don't know who asked about building to Kira's house
Right now, there's no one here but him.
That someone like you was in my junior high school
I was a troubled child in many
ways If we can talk about it, then it's time to say goodbye, right?
But that's
not a big disk for you too
Yes, but
if you should tell someone about me, then I'll be
thoroughly cornered
That
's right, get your beloved brother involved Oh
me  You
know that I don't get involved in unnecessary things, right? In order for me to be who I am,
I need to get rid of everyone who knows my past, right
?  If that's the
case, am I your
prey?